well welcome uh everybody to our second
live stream conversation uh which we're
planning to make into a recurring series
I'm Zach Weissmuller joined by my
colleague Nick Gillespie and our guest
Joan Goldberg
um
and uh of the dispatch and we're going
to talk about the recent election in
Italy which saw the ascendants of the
brothers of Italy party to power as the
governing Coalition and uh likely paves
the way for Italy's first female prime
minister Giorgio Maloney the reaction
has been Swift severe many commentators
have characterized this as the return of
fascism in Italy pointing to some of the
past associations and political imagery
as evidence that neo-fascists are now in
charge on the other hand some American
conservatives have said the rhetorics
over the top uh the left is just
throwing around the term fascist again
to discredit a political movement they
don't like so we thought talking through
this with Jonah would be worthwhile
because he published a bestseller on
this very topic called liberal fascism
in 2008 and at the same time he's become
known as one of the most persistent and
incisive critics of the brand of
right-wing populism that Trump brought
into the Republican party and which
we're seeing take hold in many places in
Europe besides Italy places like Hungary
and even Sweden so I want to start with
you Jonah on this question of fascism
you wrote in your book that fascism is
really this very slippery concept uh he
called it an academic version of
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle and
that the closer you look at it the less
clearly defined it becomes so without
warning in mind what is your kind of
overarching understanding of fascism
yeah so I mean I think an easier way to
sort of think about it is that there's a
simple version of trying to under there
are two simple ways of understanding
Fascism and there's one extremely
complicated way
um uh
there's first of all there's the actual
doctrine of fascism that was put forth
fascism is an invented term
um it derives from
the the fascis which is that bundle of
sticks around an ax was a symbol of
Roman Authority symbol over Etruscan
Authority before that
um and the basic fundamental meaning of
it is strength in numbers right it's
like all these sticks around the accent
shows that you know we're stronger
together kind of thing strength and
unity and so uh the the fascism that
Mussolini came up with originally comes
from the left it was originally uh he
was one of uh Europe's leading
socialists he actually earned the title
ilduche as the head of the Socialists in
Italy not as the head of the fascists
um the first campaign that the Italian
fascists did was explicitly as left wing
and then some of the scholars or
historians of the period say well he
moved that's when he learned to move
right and my argument would be that was
when he learned to move populist and
nationalist but not necessarily right on
any
um policy sense and so you can look at
the doctor you know they're they're
probably one of the problems you get
with this version of fascism is that it
uh it changes over time because
Mussolini keeps changing the definitions
keeps rewriting what the thing means but
that's one way to look at it another way
to look at it it's just a form of
authoritarianism
and
um you know nationalistic
authoritarianism and
I'd be perfectly happy with that except
the problem is you then get to the
complicated way of thinking about
fascism which is this way where the
academic left and and the activists left
for much of the 20th century and 21st
century was absolutely determined to
make it seem like it was the polar
opposite of Communism or bolshevism or
or or castroism or whatever that these
things were at either side of the
political Spectrum the extreme right and
the extreme left
um and it's just it just makes no sense
if you gave someone sort of a field
guide to walk around the 20th century
and you said and you Define fascism as a
unitary authoritarian leader who seizes
the means of production and controls
industry and stifles free speech and
does this and does that and is heavily
into militarism and the Civil realm as
well as the the external Realm there's
no way you can say that Castro was the
opposite of a fascist but Mussolini was
a fascist so people start getting really
really clever and never mind how trying
to describe Stalin right who fought
World War II is the Great Patriotic War
for Mother Russia
um so it gets very complicated because
people want to make it sound like these
things are very different and my
argument is is that
um borrowing from Richard pipes the
intellectual historian at Harvard uh uh
deceased now I think but um he said look
basically bolshevism and Nazism are both
heresies of socialism they both have
their roots in the Socialist radical
revolutionary tradition they play on the
same sort of emotional types it's just
that fascism understood that nationalism
is more appealing to people in a single
country than Universal class solidarity
which is what Marxist was Marxism was
based on and so just I'll rap here but
if you look around at the 20th century
um basically all basically every
successful socialist Revolution under
not talking about Democratic ones but
like serious Marxist Communists they all
become nationalistic China becomes
nationalistic the Soviet Union becomes
nationalistic because nationalism turns
out is the only way to glue together the
people because abstract Concepts about
you know dialectical materialism don't
do the trick but nationalistic appeals
to blood and soil and shared memory and
all that do and so I would argue that
basically most communist regimes are
essentially fascistic and most fascistic
regimes are essentially socialists I
noticed that yeah sorry uh let me just
throw in one thing there because I
noticed there was a response to one of
the tweets promoting this that someone
said that I think uh this guy's name der
einsteidler one I think it it's an error
of thinking to call it fascism Socialism
or communism as we think of them
collectivism covers it all the sacrifice
of individual rights in favor of an
agenda I mean I kind of like that
formulation just because I'm in favor of
individual rights and individualism
um is that a fair kind of way to think
about these movements and and the
opposition
um or or is that yeah sure if you want
to if you want to keep it simple it's
just authoritarian collectivism right
and and it's just one of Flavor one
brand name among many different brand
names and there's subtle distinctions
about the kind of rhetoric they use the
kind of appeals that they make their
relationship with organized religion and
in this place is but not in that place
and that kind of thing but it's just
really not particularly complicated and
it's amazing if you talk to people who
grew up in Eastern Europe
where you know they come from places
where both Communists and fascists
um or Nazis ran things for a while
at the area of like where the rubber
meets the row of Road of lived
experience the distinctions between
these things are very very small because
all authoritarian militaristic regimes
are basically the same in the in their
their crushing of human Liberty and all
the rest and so
we've the the problem with the word
fascist is it's it's evolved into you
know I mean Orwell spotted this in
politics and English language in 46 he
said look fascists has simply come to
mean anything not desirable and so I
mean it has to drive you Libertarians
absolutely bad because it drives me
Baddie to have people who are
Libertarians called fascist as if like
the Nazis were these big free marketers
and privatizers or something it's just
but if the left doesn't like it they
call it fascist and that has its roots
in Soviet Doctrine but we're that's too
far afield for now
yeah uh can I ask uh just very quickly
could you talk a little bit about how
Franco
fits into uh you know not not whether or
not he's the true fascist or not but how
did Francois Spain
um you know what was the flavor of you
know kind of authoritarianism that was
there and do you think that in a weird
way I mean he kind of disappeared uh
because Spain was a basket case for most
of the 20th century but is it his kind
of version of of authoritarianism that
seems to be coming back in a big way
yeah so it's an interesting question and
if I may I mean just because he fuses
religion and uh you know and a past like
you know every country creates a
national myth but he had a pretty long
you know success he had an incredibly
long run
um and a lot of it was appeals to a
golden age
um but not as elaborate you know perhaps
as like the invented Nazi past past or
Mussolini's linkage of modern Italy
which is a product of
of the 19th century to ancient Rome
yeah so it's it's an interesting
question
um
I think there are a couple things going
on first of all a lot of fascists
Scholars of fascism
have kind of come around to the idea at
least last time I dived deep into this
come around to the idea that that fascia
Spain wasn't actually fascist
um the phalanges or whatever they call
themselves The the party of Franco they
would put out press releases saying yeah
we're not that
um and you got to remember that
Spain stayed out of World War II didn't
want to have any part of any of that
kind of stuff and in fact the safest
place to be in all of Continental Europe
if you were a Jew was Spain
um and refugees from all over displaced
Jewish refugees from all over the place
first went to Italy because they knew
they'd be safe there
um until 1938 where not the Nazis
basically take over but beyond that they
all went South to Spain because Franco
was not a genocidal anti-semite neither
was Mussolini but anyway so there's the
part of it is that he was just a classic
authoritarian cordillo right-wing kind
of dictator
um not looking to export Revolution or
any of that kind of stuff
I think one of the reasons why he is so
Frozen in people's imaginations as like
this face of fascism is because of the
Spanish Civil War which was the testing
ground for the contest between the
Soviet Union and Nazi Germany and you
had so many particularly Western like
American intellectual uh pro-soviet
Communists fellow Travelers whatever who
went and either chronicled it or fought
in like the Lincoln brigades and that
kind of thing that the propaganda about
the rightists in the Civil War was so
wildly disproportionate to the reality
um and it just sort of hung there and
stuck because they had sort of a sense
of personal grievance and that I think
the hang time of that stuck with people
but you can be a right-wing dictator and
we all agree right-wing dictators are
bad without being a totalitarian right
certainly without being a fascist
certainly without being a genocidal you
know murderer we've had lots and lots of
right-wing dictators out there and
left-wing dictators
um I think right-wing dictators I'm a
gene Kirkpatrick guy I think they're
generally better for countries because
so long as no one questions their rule
uh they leave a lot of Civil Society a
lot of Institutions alone because they
don't have this let's start over at year
zero mentality but um uh yeah I don't I
don't think Franco I I think there are
very few people who would put Franco in
the same
box as as certainly as Hitler or even of
Mussolini do you think though that that
model because you know one of the things
that we're you know we are still talking
about totalitarianism as if it's 1940.
um and realistically most governments
and and you know China is an interesting
case study to think about this in terms
of authoritarian regimes but for the
most part they are not trying to get
into every single nook and cranny every
aspect of lived experience uh they you
know uh expansive governments are happy
to kind of let people go about their
business somewhat
um you know that I mean you know the the
totalitarianism that you you know see
figured in books like 1984.
um you know like it it's been tried and
it's failed
um and so then you get something more
like uh perhaps a Francois regime where
there are a lot of appeals to the past
to uniformity to solidarity
um certainly to the authority of the
government but uh you know they're
they're not trying to come into your
house and dictate that everything that
you have in your house perfectly matches
some kind of totalizing ideology or
philosophy yeah I mean it's worth just
if anything that's just trivia it's
worth pointing out that Mussolini is the
guy who actually creates the word
totalitarianism and he did not mean it
as an evil thing right I mean this is
one of these things that's very hard for
people who look at who who think that
like the Nazis chose to be the bad guys
and be portrayed as evil people by
British actors in movies for a thousand
years
um
Mussolini was not saying
totalitarianism was the way that we
think of totalitarianism or the way Hana
aren't or anybody who wrote about
totalitarianism he thought of it more as
like a holistic way right right everyone
everyone's included everyone belongs
everything within the state nothing
outside of the state but the state
wasn't this controlling evil thing it
was this you know familial body politic
no one left behind kind of sense
um so the original No Child Left Behind
in some ways you know and um uh and so I
agree like China's kind of a problematic
case because of the
the the the social credit score stuff
and North Korea is kind of a problematic
case
um the Taliban you could say is like
totalitarian in the sense that yeah
they're very few nooks and crannies of
life that you have any agency right
according to these kinds of things but
um the kind of
soft totalitarianism which I think is
something Hayek and others wrote about
that you can you can see in the west has
more to do with
um robust
Civil Society sort of media cultural
shaming and bullying then it has to do
with sort of State driven things
although I think the state can play a
role in some of that stuff and in
negative ways Title IX stuff and all
that
um it's more crowdsourced
totalitarianism but it is holistic in
the sense you're talking about that and
this you know it's a kind of bastardized
version I I've always thought of
Enlightenment systems of thinking where
it's like you are figuring it all out
and you're creating a unified field
Theory and in a way you know what we're
talking about here is an
authoritarianism perhaps uh in Italy
where it's like everything fits into the
system and if it doesn't it gets kicked
out you know it might be silence it
might have you know castor oil poured
down its throat until it it dies you
know there are various ways to deal with
it or the system adapts to it but the
idea you know and this is something
every environmentalist I think every
Christian Catholic integralist
understands that like all things are
connected we live in a world now we're
doing systems thinking which was kind of
new a novel when it started being
applied to uh you know things like uh uh
environmentalism in the 60s but that's
the world everybody thinks it in that
way and so for the same reason that you
know you shouldn't buy from a company
that employs slave labor or children in
factories this is the world we're living
in where we think every everything is
fractal every every action every part of
our Lives contains the everything else
uh yeah I agree that entirely and and
it's right once you start once you buy
into that it's kind of like wow where
does this stop you know right so I
sometimes I just want to have it I want
to have a quiet cup of coffee without
worrying where the [ __ ] beans come
from or you know whether or not I you
know is it is it immoral for a man to
stand while he pees because women can't
do that I mean you know you just wanna
you want out of the system for okay
right so I agree with that entirely I've
been saying for 20 years that the single
most fascistic thing fascistic thing
that is said every day in America is if
you're not part of the solution you're
part of the problem this idea that you
don't have a right to exit you don't
have a right to be in a safe harbor to
not care about some issue is considered
to be you're it's like this is how Abram
Kennedy talks about
race right you're either you're either a
racist or you're an anti-racist there's
no neutral position an anti-racist
requires you to do the things that I say
prove you're an anti-racist because
you're assumed to be guilty until proven
innocent and guilt and innocence is
determined by whether or not you support
the policies I choose that's a very
fascistic uh way of thinking about
things and there's a term
I mean it's buddhistic this is like sure
I think it's very human our brains want
an integral social order I think that's
right and then one of the things about
modernity is realizing that you can only
have them at certain scale so you can
have it in your family right you can
have it in your little church but you
can't really you know it's it's high X
microcosm versus macrocosm you cannot
scale out you know the mine shaft to the
entire gazelle shaft without ruining
both right and
um the Germans I'm starting to throw
around all the German lingo but I don't
get to do it very often yeah uh the
German Nazis had a a phrase that they
stole from
um
electrical engineering I think called
like Shelton which meant coordination
and it basically said
every it's sort of it was sort of like
an updating of the sort of darwinian
stuff about the body politic which said
every institution in society needs to be
like a a chip or a transistor in a
machine all working together all
pointing in the same direction all in
service to the same ideas so one of the
things that Scholars of totalitarianism
will point out about the differences
between the Soviet Union and Nazi
Germany is that Nazi Germany seems
superficially more right-wing in part
because it allowed a lot of
old institutions to keep existing
whereas the Soviets tore them all down
and started over kind of thing and the
problem with that is that under the
theory of the glacial tongue you could
be a quote-unquote independent
fraternity at a university so long as
the leadership of the University was
sworn into and loyal to the Nazi party
program and the same thing with the
ballet company and the bowling league
and so it was a way to see to project
superficial National normalcy while at
the same time guaranteeing that all ores
pulled in the same direction and that
all descent was punished
if I may just for a final point on this
broader topic uh you know Chuck freund
uh Charles Paul trying to use right for
reason a lot I retired in the in the
odds but he talked about in the Soviet
Union how the the western music that
most freaked out the Soviets was not
rock and roll or even Jazz it was
um teeny bopper pop by people like uh uh
Neil Sedaka uh and Paul Anka where they
were singing you know kind of silly
tunes about like puppy love where it was
like because there was no political
Dimension to it at all like rock at
least it's like oh you know you're
pushing back against something or
whatever and this the thing that they
couldn't stand was the idea that there
existed a world in which politics and
ideology just did not matter and that
freaked them out and in in many ways I
you know again you know we need to draw
many many distinctions but this is part
part of what life in 21st century
Americans like you know we have people
who have dueling comprehensive holistic
systems of understanding everything from
the shower you take in the morning to
the job that you during the day and the
TV shows or the Live Theater you watch
at night and you know you either are
with the program or you're not and you
know you're either part of the solution
or you're or you're part of the problem
and um that's a uh you know it
Libertarians find this very appealing
like one of the things when you talk to
Libertarians they're like What's
appealing about it is it's a full system
it explains everything and there are
real problems with that and you know
you've been yapping about uh Friedrich
or invoking him several times I think
Hayek is one of the people who is
problematic to certain types of dogmatic
Libertarians precisely because in you
know particularly in the
counter-revolution of science which I
think is his most important book he
questioned and you know whether or not
the enlightenment was right to start
thinking about single systems that
include all of human activity because
that way Madness lies and I think we're
living in an attenuated version of the
you know of the mass you know psychosis
that came out of that that engineering
mentality in in the mid 20th century
I want to talk I think we should talk a
little bit more about Maloney's attitude
towards all this towards totalizing
systems and whether she is an advocate
of that or an opponent of that because
there was this this viral speech that
she made that a lot of conservatives
were sharing approvingly that in some
ways seems to be pushing back against
kind of you know categorizing everyone
uh from the top down but at the same
time Nick you had some uh serious
problem qualms and objections to it um
so I wanted to just play that clip and
then have me give have you give your
reaction to that and everyone this is
going to be in Italian uh it's subtitled
so if you're you're just listening it's
going to be a couple minutes of Italian
but um but there are subtitles
yeah
identity
perfect
ly
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
what's your reaction to that Nick
because she does talk a little bit about
individualism individual identity but
it's kind of a stew of different things
in there right and it's also you know
what's being opposed is the idea that
you are either this member of you know
of of a family and of a nation and of a
gender uh that it's okay or you are a
perfect consumer slave that you've been
denuded and deracinated of all thick
identity that you're born into and
culture that is around you and then you
are just like a Sitting Duck for you
know International Financial speculators
which in an Italian context in
particular is a uh you know is the way
of talking about Jewish bankers and
international Capital which exists only
to exploit people
um what what set me off about this
is uh that the you know the individual I
think what what is great about modernity
and sometimes I call it libertarian
modernity is that we have shifted from
us uh a time where you are born into a
system and that system defines you
whether it's the family whether it's the
nation whether it's the religion
whatever gender roles and things like
that modernity in one way can be looked
at as the shift and this is you know
what happens in the enlightenment the
shift from the system to the individual
getting to make more and more choices to
Define themselves as they see fit and to
move into different systems to create
new systems to try out new things and
new identities and move freely and I
think about
um you know that in the context of my
mother's parents were Italian immigrants
who moved to the United States from
Southern Italy in the mid uh 19 teens
essentially to escape World War one
where my grandfather certainly would
have been killed he was an uneducated
farmer who had been you know for a
thousand years my grandparents on both
sides My Father's Side was from Irish
Ireland but you know they were raised to
be peasants and serfs and fodder for
other people's existing systems the move
to America was a change in that and I
feel like she in the name of individual
sanctity is reasserting the idea that
God country and family are the things
that matter most
um and it just seems to me I you know at
uh particularly it's it seems to me
that's at odds with the individualism
that she is invoking and that we take
for granted in many ways in the United
States as a liberatory force when you
layer that in in an Italian context and
Italy in in a cons you know in a you
know defensible way is a failed State
sin since World War II it you know it
has a new government every every six
months every every couple of years and
they are looking for outside reasons for
why it is not working as well as it
should that worries me because in in a
European historical context when you
start blaming Outsiders for your
problems bad things follow from that her
party is insisting on you know they're
against gay marriage they are against
migration both legal and illegal they
don't like refugees coming uh they are
asserting a traditional identity uh a
traditional Italian identity that is
based on this God family country thing
which is of recent vintage the way that
they Define it the way that the you know
the Catholic Church uh which I was
raised in and I have five of seven
sacraments like I'm pretty you know I'm
pretty far up the list on that
um you know the Catholic Church changes
how it acts and what it believes over
time but it always pretends there's a
broken UNC you know unbroken chain of
succession that it goes all the way back
to Peter in Rome and these appeals to a
unified past to an overwhelming past uh
trouble me because they are a Hallmark
of authoritarianism and of of European
fascism so I mean those are some of the
things that brought my hackles up the
question for us particularly as
Libertarians particularly in America
because you know when we talk about
conservatism the way that it's being
talked about now by national
conservatives and whatnot it's like I'm
an individual do I have the agency uh to
make my choices and do we respect the
idea that we should be expanding
individual Choice making not restricting
it in the name of getting back to some
kind of unified uh social order yeah so
Jonah I tend to agree with NYX reading
that there's a kind of cramped idea of
what individualism is uh in in the
vision she's putting forth there but um
you know these are the kinds of things
that I've been hearing conservatives
complain about for a long time attacks
uh by Progressive by the progressive
elite on the family on religion
traditional gender identity so it's it's
easy for me to see why some American
conservatives and even some Libertarians
have shared this enthusiastically do you
think that her complaints here have a
valid basis yeah I'm more let me put it
this way I'm more sympathetic than you
guys are to what she said without being
particularly sympathetic
um in the sense that first of all
as long as they stay a democratic and
fairly decent country
really couldn't give a rat's ass how
Italy does its politics right they can't
they can't invade Ethiopia right um
there are a bunch of things they can't
do but like I'm kind of reminded of the
Jackie Mason routine where Jackie Mason
was like it's weird with Jews and
Italians you put
a Jew in a uniform and he can kick
everybody's ass but like a Jew out of
uniform is this guy you pick on on the
schoolyard and an Italian
out of uniform they're incredibly tough
but you put them in uniform and like
they fall apart and of course it's
unfair he was a comedian but like
fascist Italy just you know did some
Terrible Things some people were put to
death lots of people were beaten up and
thrown in jail lots of property was
taken away I'm not defending any of that
it just
the Italians were sort of incapable of
being as brutal and ruthless and
terrible as Nazis were
um in part because biological racism
just doesn't work in a country like like
Italy and so and she herself has said
Italy is in the graveyard and we're done
I mean fascism is in the grave where
it's dead we're not bringing that back
until she proves otherwise I kind of
feel like we can take a word for it
where I have so I have
I have no problem with wanting to
protect the family I think the family is
hugely important I think I have no
problem with wanting to give space to
religion particularly in a country like
Italy right I I like that all makes
sense to me where I sort of my where my
record needle scratches is when she says
we're not going to be victims and turned
into Raw uh consumers by Financial
speculators because yeah
what the hell is that I mean like it's
like she can't attack the state because
she wants the state to be very strong
and this sort of scapegoating thing
um is weird
um and I agree with Nick that it has
there's something ominous about it
because it's essentially a conspiracy
theory and the idea that markets don't
respond to the needs of families is kind
of weird
um the idea that markets can't respond
to the needs of these various forms of
identity is kind of weird markets are
always looking for markets
um and they cater to anybody who has
strong preferences and there's no reason
why there's this this idea that there's
Relentless capitalist assault on on
family or faith or any of these kinds of
things what bothers me in the American
context is
why the hell are people sort of saying
yeah let's do that here I mean like
America is not Italy it's not Hungary
the degree to which people talk about
some of them very good friends of mine
you know talk about Hungary the way the
left talked about Cuba or Sweden or
Russia in previous eras is creepy and
weird to me and for what it is to me is
it's basically
it's sort of it's a mix of power worship
and propaganda where you just sort of
say look they're getting away with stuff
I kind of like that's how we so we
should do that here and I'll be in
charge the way Victor Orban is in charge
over there and we'll get everything that
we want and democracy and liberalism and
all this stuff gets in our way
um it's very reminiscent of like Tom
Freeman looking at China in the 1990s
and saying you know he actually wrote a
chapter of his book called China for a
day where he wanted to just sort of be
an authoritarian quasi-totalitarian
one-party state for a day so he get all
his favorite policies implemented
um it's it's a very old form of American
intellectual power worship
and it's incredibly dangerous it's in
many ways anti-American and I don't mean
that in sort of like a sort of glib way
I mean like literally it's not the
American tradition to say let's go like
on one of those game shows with a
shopping cart through Europe and just
grab totally alien ideas and contexts
and throw them in our cart and bring
them to America and oppose them here
Americans are not Italians we're not
even freaking Canadians and the idea
that you can go shopping in Hungary or
or Italy or Russia and grab ideas that
you're going to impose with the state
in the United States is completely a
tell on what your actual motives are and
very little to do with any sort of
serious political program
this I mean it's what what you're
alluding to here is this rise of
national conservatism in America and
um these are the people who are largely
cheering the rise of Maloney in in Italy
and Orban and Hungary I I just wonder
you know you said on one hand you don't
really care much about what happens in
Italy on the other hand you know we had
we all remember brexit kind of preceding
the rise of trump like should we be
thinking about it in those terms do you
think is this kind of a Bellwether of
you know what's coming to America oh
that's fair I mean if you're talking
about it as a canary in the coal mine
about the kind of politics that are
coming that's a perfectly legitimate
thing to care about and
um
and again I did caveat saying I want
Italy to stay a decent and Democratic
country I also wanted to stay a country
that I would like to be a tourist in you
know um but uh um but they're free to
figure out things as they go I have I
like I like real diversity you know
diversity of institution diversity of
ways of seeing the world I want you know
I want European countries to feel like
they're a different country When I visit
them so I give leeway to other countries
that I wouldn't give to my own
um but yeah look I mean I think there's
there's a
a really important article in I want to
say is the European Journal of political
science but it might have the title
wrong
a few years ago which studied basically
every recession and depression going
back I think to the 1830s and it found
that
um
Financial crises in particular ones that
Financial crises that cause recessions
in particular have very long populist
Tales because there's something so
dislocating about financial crises other
than like other economic shocks you know
you lose your mortgage it's not just
that you lose your job you sort of you
feel like
the system lied to you and I think that
um
the financial shock of 2007-2008 created
made Trump possible it made the tea
parties possible it made Occupy Wall
Street possible it made Bernie Sanders
someone that people take seriously
um and I think we are still in the long
tail of populism from that to a certain
degree
um there are other things that fuel
populism the changing nature of
Automation and and and and and all that
um I think social media makes everything
worse in lots of ways so it's worth
paying attention to to be sure but you
know
the idea I'm like I I wrote about this
recently I lived in Prague for a very
short period of time Matt Welch was
there when I got there and he was there
after I left he was there much longer
but um uh I remember talking to people
about the Yugoslav Civil War at the time
which was going which was really getting
going back then and there were already
murmurs about the slovakians wanting to
leave Czechoslovakia and I kept asking
checks you know uh do you think there's
gonna be a war like that here and the
checks said no I'm not going to kill
people to keep Slovakia and slovakians
were like I'm not going to kill people
to like leave you know it's just not it
doesn't work no way and the only reason
I bring it up is like in in the early
1990s we had a lot of talk about the
balkanization and the breakdown of the
international order and all this kind of
stuff because the Soviet Union and and
all that
different countries are different I mean
again Nazi Germany and fascist Italy
very different countries what happens in
Italy doesn't necessarily come here and
if it does come here it won't be the
same thing as that happened in Italy
because Italians are different than
Americans I think um I I agree with that
completely but uh Zach I also think
you're right to kind of put it in the
context of brexit which also reminds me
of brexit and Trump in a way are good
illustrations of Martin gury's argument
and the Revolt of the uh uh but the
Revolt public
um you know that we are in an age now
where it is relatively easy to mobilize
forces that tear things down but then
you know and and they're they're
responding to failures and systems to
actually deliver what they say they're
going to do but then they don't know
what to do next and brexit you know I
mean it's it's amazing because the
brexit vote happened and it's still not
really completed and they've gone
through a couple of different you know
and they'll go through a couple
different more Prime Ministers and
governments before they probably end up
coming back to something that's
relatively close to what the EU was uh
or England's response
um with the with the Italian situation
here and particularly those appeals to
God country and family and I am a I'm a
huge uh admirer of the way at various
points that you know the Catholic church
in Central Europe was one of the main
bulwarks against communism it absolutely
worked uh not you know depending on
where you are the Soviets tried to break
down the nuclear family you know so did
the Israeli government in its early days
because they recognize that families are
oftentimes uh counter forces to you know
to the state or to other sources of
power so like I understand all of these
groups uh you know religion family uh
national identity can act as a powerful
hedge and pushback against a larger
assert you know uh Insurgent force and I
think that's all good but what worries
me is when people want to stop that
movement because they say no our version
of what we're talking about is good and
now the individual the individual's
right to decide or choose can go to hell
I think what we're seeing in Italy and
certainly actually [ __ ] Italy for now
you know there's my my you know my
family left a hundred years ago so I
don't have to worry about it anymore but
in the United States I think what you're
seeing among a lot of national
conservatives is at the precise moment
when the United States is becoming more
diverse there are more types of people
in the country than ever before and they
are mixing in New mongrelizing in new
ways that I personally I'm drawn to I
find exciting there's a reason why after
30 years I moved back to New York
because I want to be in a place that is
a mixing you know a Melting Pot in a
mixing bowl and all of that kind of
stuff it's not for everyone but the way
National conservatives talk about this
is it is too disruptive it's too chaotic
I am lost and my traditions and my
culture and my meaning and they want to
rigidify what is considered an
acceptable identity what is considered
an acceptable life philosophy fee or
lifestyle and things like that and to me
I find that I find that really
um disturbing
um because what national conservatives
are doing and Jen I'd be interested in
your sense of the shift from an older
version of conservativism that you were
raised in and you you know helped kind
of articulate in the course of your
career National conservatives are now
saying you know we should use the state
to enforce our vision of the good life
that is
I want to layer one thing on top of that
to have Jonah address because you know
looking at the Italian situation in
particular you know there was a vote of
no confidence against the government
um as they have faced this increasing
economic pressure both from the covid-19
lockdowns and earned just the pandemic
generally and also the war in between
Ukraine and Russia and Maloney
interestingly was I mean she was very
she's been against she came out against
the lockdowns this has been like an
animating thing in the United States
against kind of the Progressive Movement
here is a backlash to a lot of the covid
policies that were enacted by Blue State
Governors but there's this weird irony
which I think Nick is talking about here
where the solution being presented is
well
um not we need a kind of libertarian
reset it's that we need a right wing
social engineering type of reset like
the left is captured all the
institutions so it's not that we need to
reduce the power of the government it's
that we need the right to recapture all
the institutions and form them to our
liking how did this happen is this good
and can we you know Escape that or or
offer some sort of alter like viable
alternative yeah so there's a lot there
um uh I'm glad you brought up the
pandemic I think that's another thing
just get that out of the way that fuels
populists you're so right about uh you
know I would say even even 9 11 but
certainly the financial crisis and covet
like we we haven't actually kind of
accounted for what a major impact the
financial crisis and the and the slow
recovery from the recession yeah really
is and you know one of the things just
to add into that is that what's amazing
to me is people that I know who are
under 30 or say under 35 have kind of
become adults in a system that they feel
doesn't speak to them so it's not even
like they're disillusioned it's like
they have only you know it it's not like
they were riding high and then they lost
their job it's like they don't even get
the job that they were promised yeah and
the the and and similarly I think the
pandemic
like I think it's in the John Berry book
about the great influenza like when the
when the last pandemic you know 100
years ago ended
people just didn't really want to talk
about it they were sort of so ashamed of
how they behaved and I think a lot of
people behave badly on both the left and
the right during the pandemic because
our brains are wired to like deal with
invisible enemies in all sorts of
complicated ways and our the political
as Jonathan Knight will tell you the
political centers of Iran are very close
to the concern about hygiene the centers
of our brain so anyway that that aside I
think
look I want to be clear about something
I think most of the national
conservatism talk is uh [ __ ]
um and I mean that in a in a pretty
serious way I think
um
we can get into the analytical stuff and
there I mean and there are some serious
people who are into it I just think
they're just wrong and they're caught up
in what they think is an idea whose time
has come but they're decent people and
all of that but I also think there are a
lot of young people in particular who
are I want to get into we're since
talking about Italy I don't want to get
into Italian elite theory but there are
a lot of people who see this as a way to
skip a whole bunch of rungs in the
ladder and be the leader of a new
movement
that they think will take over and then
when they take over they'll be much
higher than they would be if they paid
their dues working up the old ladder and
so there are a bunch of kind of
desperate people who are getting on a
bandwagon uh at a time of legitimate
vulnerability for traditional
conservatism and saying you know I'd
rather start a new club than be the
assistant Treasurer in this
long-standing club and I I I think that
explains a lot of the passion about this
stuff is is it's careerism and ambition
less than serious ideas
um and one of the tells about that
um you know and Nick and I are two
people will actually like
care a great deal about sort of weird
quirky ideological intellectual history
is that none of their ideas were
like the the post-liberal integralist
Catholic guys this was the exact
argument that was going on between uh
sort of within the National Review World
between uh bozell who started a magazine
called Triumph and National Review all
of these arguments are pretty old most
of them were defeated at various times
um
and uh a lot of it is just sort of
warmed over beganism in a lot of ways
um
I think
a big chunk of it is also just simply
um
uh
uh product of the hyper polarized time
that we're in and I you know one of the
things I you know there are a lot of
things I would do differently if I were
right liberal fascism again
um one of the things I regret is I'm one
of the people most responsible for
injecting
um this Obsession about Saul Alinsky
into the right
and um
but I wrote about salonski as a bad guy
right I was like this guy is a bad guy
he cheats he lies he thinks everything
is permissible nearest weapon to hand
politics it's immoral and bad and there
was some weird stuff that happened on
the right where it first became sort of
respect your enemies oh the left uses
these tactics and then very quickly it
became we have to use them too
that you get these people who behave as
bad as they imagine their political
enemies behave
and not even actually how they actually
behave but like the worst versions in
their imagination of their enemies they
now think we have to do it that's
bannonism that's so much of this stuff
where it's like it's like own the libs
and liberal tears or delicious stuff has
now become the aim of it rather than
sort of an ancillary benefit and I think
that's unsustainable and irresponsible
and intellectually indefensible what's
your uh so what's your response to their
fundamental critique that kind of
playing nice or within the those
boundaries those uh you know those Norms
is just a losing strategy I mean Jonah
you are just apologizing yet again for
David frenchism aren't you yeah so um I
think all of that I don't say all of
that because look there is I share a lot
of you know like I'm still a
conservative so there are some things I
share concerns about with people who
call themselves conservatives
but I mean I just take the the example
that I find most annoying is this idea
that you get from this this new sort of
common good constitutionalism crowd and
whenever you hear common good
um from a right winger now just think
it's social justice for right Wingers
it's that's just what they're talking
about right social justice for the left
basically means everything we want is
social justice
um it's a permission structure for
saying we should just be in charge and
get the things that we want and the
common good conservatism stuff is
basically the same thing and so you're
there's this argument that you get from
a lot of these people particularly these
people are very hungry and ambitious to
um you know rise much faster in like the
legal profession
um who
just assert that
liberal constitutionalism you know that
originalism
is uh morally neutral
um that it's procedural liberalism and
that conservatives will always lose in
contests over procedural liberalism that
complaint died down a little bit after
Dobbs I have to point out but
the idea
that the liberalism inherent in the
Constitutional structure
is somehow value neutral is
mind-bogglingly stupid right the idea
that you should have the right to face
your accuser in court
is not morally neutral the right that
you should have a jury of your peers is
not morally neutral the right that you
have a right to your property is not
morally neutral the right that you have
the right to re to worship as you see
feet see fit to speak your conscience to
move freely none of these things are
morally neutral they are in fact
profoundly moral policies and
commitments that human beings murdered
each over over for centuries to reach as
a sort of this postless failion
compromise about how to run a society
and to all of a sudden say that if if a
neutral process which is another way of
saying a fair process
right that applies to everybody the same
which is a very moral position to take
that if we don't win everything that
just proves the system doesn't work I
think it's so profoundly misguided and
dangerous and the the the the level of
Underpants known thinking in so much of
this is just mind-boggling step one we
purge the old fusionist right and the
Libertarians who ran Washington for 30
years
step two question mark question mark
question mark step three total Victory I
mean you had JD Vance talking about what
that the the government should seize the
assets of the Ford foundation and give
them to displaced workers in Ohio or
something like that right can you talk
you want to put it into law that the
government gets to seize you talk about
fascism gets to seize the assets of
ideological opponents and give them to
their allies I mean this how could that
work badly for conservatives when the
government doesn't run by us you know
can I ask how much you know you you
touched on it a bit
um how much of this is generational in a
way that is almost independent of
ideology because there's a version of
this going on on the left too where you
know you have Bernie Sanders and you
have gray beards but both on both sides
you know you have a lot of people older
Gen X people now and certainly Boomers
who are fitter than ever and living
longer and not vacating the stage and
you have you know a press of younger
people regardless of ideology who are
just like get the [ __ ] out of my way and
I find you know there's just that
pressure sure that like you know we
gotta we gotta unstop the toilet here uh
which is a very unfortunate metaphor
which makes no sense and I apologize for
it uh now and forever unstopping it from
below yeah
but one of the things that I find kind
of fascinating about it is and again
this is this is irrespective of ideology
is that the 60s generation for lack of a
better term when they were when they
were facing that a lot of them just went
out and built their own institutions
they built their own communes whether
they were right-wing organizations or
left-wing I mean even Buckley's you know
in like the 50s who's the ultimate
establishment guy like went out and
built a new magazine that created you
know in in a in a 50-year run
transformed into the American political
landscape and cultural landscape and
that to me is one of the things that's
most frustrating is that you have that
useful exuberance and sense of
entitlement that the future is ours and
we want it now you know everybody is
like uh
everybody is like Jim Morrison
um but they're not saying and we're
gonna go build our own stage they're
gonna say we're going to take it from
you
um and it just that you know so it's
it's I and now I'm really showing my age
but it's like spoiled children you know
it all the kids today are all Veruca
Salt they're not gonna go build their
own Factory and buy stuff they're just
gonna get it from the people who have
already made the money yeah so I mean
we're pretty much on the same Gen X page
on this um if you look at so many of the
controversies at the New York Times or
the Atlantic and a lot of these
mainstream liberal institutions or if
you talk to some of the people who you
know run those places or at NBC or MSNBC
you know I have friends in various these
places the Baby Boomers and gen xers are
just flat out terrified of the young
staffers and I think that one of the
things and so like a lot of a lot of the
metoo stuff turned out to be far more
legitimate and there were far fewer
cases of exaggeration than that than I
would have expected but when you look at
some of the like the woke controversies
the guy who used the n-word of the New
York Times who's just sort of like
pulled down even though the way he used
it was utterly defensible
um uh a lot of these things I think are
exactly that they are it's a Masthead
struggle yeah it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's the the youngins getting
frustrated I think the one of the
Dynamics that I don't think it's nearly
the coverage or sociological
investigation that it deserves
is like you know how in like the the
French Revolution and several
revolutions since
uh
the revolutionaries were like college
students and young people who got worked
up in saloons or bars right or cafes and
they would egg each other on and they
get all worked up and let's go build a
barricade you know blah blah blah I
think slack channels at some of these
institutions play the same role and like
my understanding is that the New York
Times the people who are allowed in like
the group chat and are included like
like the newspaper delivery Union
officials whatever and since these kids
are so
cowed by charges of sexism or homophobia
or whatever that
you you get this Dynamic where everyone
has to prove that they're part part of
the glacial tongue right everyone has to
prove that they're part of the group
think and they are not dissenters from
it that they get whipped up and then it
spills out in public and you're like why
is everybody starting at a level of
anger at like nine at something that
seems so innocuous and it's because
we're not seeing what's going on in
these virtual you know saloons of
revolutionary Paris
uh Jonah how much longer do we have you
for I can hang out for a little bit more
it's fine okay okay right well yeah but
before you before you have to go I did
want to bring up one specific topic
which always
um comes up uh anytime you come on
reasons platform we get a lot of people
you know saying we need to grill you
about foreign policy and I just wanted
to bring it up in the context of you
know it's something that I think is an
underrated driver of the right-wing
populist phenomenon
um most Americans you know don't put it
at the top of their list according to
polling but there is a sort of realism
On The Rise and you know I I do come
from a pretty non-interventionist
perspective
um there's a there's this recognition I
think among Americans that we we can't
endlessly spend money supporting other
people's fights around the world and if
you go back to every modern U.S
presidential election you know as far
back let's say as George W bush not
involving an incumbent the more
rhetorically non-interventionistic
candidate has been that's been the
winner
um up through Trump
um and so I'm just wondering you know is
there perhaps a lesson here that both
the center left and center right need to
learn if they want to prevent their own
obsolescence because I you know in terms
of protecting institutions and you know
not burning it all down that's something
I've come to have a much more a greater
appreciation for an affinity with uh
conservatives on in recent years and I
think that's something we need uh in our
politics and it's something I've
criticized within the libertarian
movement as well uh but the you know the
foreign policy question I think is a is
a big divide and a big rift there and um
you know have you ever thought about it
in that context
um because that is one aspect of
national conservatism and and certainly
trumpism
yeah no it's an interesting question
it's a good question it's something and
look depending on who's demanding that
I'd be grilled about foreign policy
there are things I wrote 20 years ago
that I would not write today and we I
don't need to list them all but if
someone's running around quotes from
something from a long time ago you know
50 something year old Jonah is different
than 20 something year old Jonah that
said
um
there are a couple things going on with
the question that I think are
interesting and I mean this in a totally
good faith way one is
uh
you could actually turn the question
around and we're supposed to be sitting
here talking about how we're troubled by
national conservatism
I could ask you guys as Libertarians
does it trouble you that that the
national conservatives are moving in
your direction on foreign policy what
does that say about your foreign policy
commitments
second
um
you said you know like you made this
point about presidential elections and I
think it's a good point
um
I I I I I'm gonna put an aster I'm gonna
put a pin in it because I might question
it
to some degree but let's just stipulate
that it's true that not more I know more
non-interventionist foreign policy is
more popular
um
that may be true
um I suspect that it's always true until
a bunch of jihadis cut off a bunch of
American journalist heads or uh dictator
invades a democratic country or a
country trying to become Democratic
um Americans the the Jacksonian part of
America that I like
is that uh
you know we want to get like think about
getting out out of Afghanistan
Joe Biden shared very much the the
netcon and for a lot of Libertarians
libertarian position on foreign policy
we just got to get out 20 years of war I
had a long uh back and forth Peter
suderman about this and uh
and the thing is is that yeah
as a generic proposition I want to get
out of Afghanistan lots of Americans
want to go to Afghanistan what they
don't want is to be humiliated or feel
like the investment wasn't worth it or I
feel like they lost a war and the bad
guys took over and so opinions wildly
changed after Biden screwed up the
withdrawal from that country people's
Americans attitudes with about foreign
policy I think are much less simplistic
than a lot of the ideological arguments
about this stuff
um would make it seem
and
regardless
again stipulating that you're right
about the popularity of
non-interventionism which again I don't
think holds steady in the way that maybe
the framing suggests but let's say it is
it's popular
simply because something is popular
doesn't necessarily mean it's the right
policy and one of the reasons we're why
we can't have nice things one of the
reasons I argue with the netcon guys all
the time and always yell at me so don't
you understand this is what Republican
voters want don't you understand this is
what Americans want and my position is
I don't care it's still the wrong thing
to do I've been writing against populism
for 20 years and it used to Mark me as
sort of a conservative and good standing
now it marks me as a [ __ ]
um and the thing is is like you know as
Kevin Williamson says you know
you know the other day we were talking
on uh one of these kinds of things and
someone said you know well this is what
the American people want and he said
well that's the first strike against it
you know
um I don't put uh I think democracy and
populism are very different for SP for
all sorts of ways but one of them is the
procedural mechanical way about making
decisions as channeled through elections
through elected officials who sort of
are supposed to apply their judgment and
their Prudence to a question and not
simply be rote respondents to to voters
populism isn't even about voting it's
just about pure anger and the idea of
listening to the Mob and when people say
to me all the time I mean you don't
understand people are really angry they
just you just don't get that they're so
angry I was like okay no I think I get
that they're angry since they vent their
anger at me almost every single day I
get the sense
but let me ask you when was the last
time you made a really good Sound
Decision when you were blindingly angry
about something that's not how you're
supposed to do politics so I'm
completely open to arguments about
retrenchment in foreign policy about
going a different way I you're gonna
have to work really hard to say we
should get out of NATO or something like
that but that's fine
um but if you're just going to say well
this is what polls say or this is what a
focus group says or this is what a bunch
of people shouting
um say or what people who phone in you
know who like email in to Tucker
Carlson's TV show could not give a rat's
ass about it because that's not an
argument
could you talk briefly you mentioned
buchananite and I'm curious if a lot of
our audience here may not know who
you're referring to
um James Buchanan one of the greatest
presidents of the United States yeah I
mean he's right you know he's the
bachelor too so he had that going
forward he had his weekend's free no but
Pat Buchanan uh you know bestowed the
Earth like a Colossus you know when we
were you know making our careers uh you
know and I mean basically you know from
about 1970 until what maybe 2005 2010 at
the latest I mean he was a giant figure
and in the 90s he you know took on
George H.W bush he took on the
Republican establishment and was
articulating a populist line he was
against you know he was he he pushed
culture War battles that were still
being fought about now
um you know about gay rights or
alternative Lifestyles and things like
that but he was also a you know weirdly
a non-interventionist while sometimes a
cold war hawk but how important is he
not not as a direct figure but like his
thinking to a kind of Republican or
conservative party crack up
yeah so I mean so again Pat Buchanan ran
in 92 and again in 96
um it's interesting I just wrote about
this yesterday but you know in 96 he was
a protectionist he was a immigration
restrictionist in uh robustly he was
um he was for industrial policy he
played cute dog whistle games about how
he was against affirmative action but if
we're going to have it we should have it
for people like O'Malley's and and that
kind of thing so he did a lot of white
identity politics kind of Subrosa
um very anti-israel very to a point
where if I'm not mistaken I mean he was
he was dubbed you know actually
anti-semitic by uh William F Buckley in
the pages of uh of National Review if
not quite as bad as some other members
of the National Review family yeah he
played
he played footsie with things and you
know uh we were talking about Rob long
earlier but you know I have this sort of
standard line about how I have deep
roots in conservatism
um true story Pappy Cannon was at my
bris
um and Rob long said that might explain
his attitude towards the Jews
and uh he was introduced to my dad by a
guy named Victor Laskey who very few
people remember but who was actually my
brother's Godfather and Victor
introduced him to my dad and said Sid I
want you to meet Pat Buchanan he is a
terrific red baiter and it was meant as
a compliment and it was received as a
compliment so but anyway
um but it's interesting if you go back
and you look at 1996 what the American
conservative Union what the Heritage
Foundation what all sorts of like
leading institutions what National
Review you know wrote about Buchanan
they all said he's not a conservative
anymore
because he was for industrial policy he
was for sort of playing games about
identity politics he was against you
know trade yada yada and
um I bring that up in part because I get
key I keep getting told that I'm not a
conservative anymore as if I'm the one
who changed when in fact the party has
moved or I should say the Grassroots in
a bunch of Institutions have moved
towards
the buchananite position on stuff I
think some of that is the work of
Buchanan
um laying down the groundwork for some
of these things a lot of it is Trump
um and a lot of it is just sort of the
you know one of the problems we have in
the culture right now is no one is
allowed to no one wants to say they're
The Establishment everybody wants to be
the outsider and the sort of Outsider
groups are making these kind of
Pitchfork Pat buchananite kind of
arguments
um
um and so I think he has a you know he
he he's going to matter as a matter of
intellectual history in all sorts of
ways
um uh uh and he's sort of like the
dashboard saint for at least some of the
napkins I mean part of the problem
is that they're actually some really if
some profound ideological
disagreements among that whole mass of
people right the sort of
ultramontane Catholicism is kind of hard
to reconcile with National conservatism
um and and then there's the sorts of
other people are far crankier
um which is why I think it has much less
to do with intellectual coherence and
consistency and more to do with it just
where the heat is and they're all like
moss if it means anything tonight uh in
New York I'm going to uh the first
Compact magazine lecture which is a
magazine started by Sir Robert Mari Who
is the you know uh uh an Iranian convert
Catholicism who's sort of this new
magazine that's bringing together all
people Michael Lind who was an enemy of
National Review conservativism in the
90s is giving the first lecture and he's
being introduced by one of the hosts of
the Red Scare podcast and then the
Yugoslavian uh philosopher slavo zizak
is on the Mast set of compact so it's a
world which uh is Stranger than we can
imagine in in many ways can I also and I
I don't mean to preempt to Zach but this
question of nobody wants to be the
establishment is kind of fascinating
right because and I I should also add
that Pat Buchanan has had a large
influence on many libertarian thinkers
particularly people who read
lourockwell.com and uh uh you know and
are involved in like the mises Institute
because of his anti-interventionism
which is somewhat selective uh I I
remember being on TV shows with him
where he was like we got a bomb Iran and
Iraq and all of that and it's just like
you know in anything I wanted to
intervene in the Yugoslav Civil War on
behalf I believe of Kosovo right because
they're part of Christian Europe and
right all that kind of stuff but that
but that idea of Christian Europe or
Christianity whatever that means is is
somehow important to all of these people
um but that question of the
establishment it's kind of a great
moment in the sense that like so much
has been leveled I mean you left
National Review National Review is you
know as Monumental a political
institution you know certainly in
post-war America is anything else I mean
it really you know and I went to the
50th anniversary dinner which I believe
was one of the last public uh
um uh uh appearances of Bill Buckley who
was in a kind of bitter mood even though
he had you know the National Review in
in half a century had changed the
Republican party to change the political
culture it elected you know Ronald
Reagan and you know George W bush who at
first they were kind of bullish on Etc
um and now everything seems to be in
ashes like you don't want to be part of
the establishment
um wow what's going on there and is is
it a good thing that we now live in a
dispersed decentralized world where
people are fighting you know have we
gone back to you know an era of nation
states where
um you know perhaps more people can sort
to be where they want uh albeit in a
more fragmented uh kind of polity yeah I
I'm let I'm not there with you on that
um I think that um first of all just to
be clear
I have nothing but love for National
Review and my friends there and
um I I did not leave in some Grand Huff
um I left in part because after 20 years
I wanted to start a new institution and
and I thought that I was also on this
weird kick that I thought
that
I mean there are a bunch of different
reasons we don't need to get deep in the
weeds in it but one of them was I it
weirdly I felt like it kind of fell to
me
um and people like me to model the
behavior that I thought was so lacking
on the right because as you know I used
to be much more of a red meat you know
duke it out kind of guy
um
but that was always within the context
where there was like establishment
people saying Jonah ran it in ran it in
kind of thing and now they're The
Establishment people are crazy as far as
I can tell or at least a lot of them or
at least they want people to believe
they're crazy for small dollar donations
but
um
regardless
I think you've you used this phrase from
time to time that you like
um
was it like a Utopia of Utopias yeah
yeah Robert knows it yeah right
different communities serving different
people right and as long as you have the
right of exit people can be part of any
you know sort of community they want we
probably both agree that certain basic
protections about civil rights are
probably baked into that but for the
most part let a thousand flowers broom
if you want to be an Amish be an Amish
if you want to be a Hell's Angel be a
Hell's Angel whatever right
um
I
I
am
even though I will argue till I'm blue
in the face that the great and good
thing about America is that as a
political matter
the fundamental unit of the political
system
is the individual because he can't make
it the family it just doesn't work as a
procedural thing right it's got to be
the individual and that the hero and the
American political tradition is the guy
who stands up to the Mob not the mob
that is in a nutshell whatever why I
don't like populism
um but as a matter of political
philosophy of sociology
um
I want a lot more sticky institutions I
want all because I think where human
beings flourish where human beings
actually find meaning and life
satisfaction is by their membership in
groups
you know uh and in long-lived groups and
long-lived not like every five minutes
we're starting an expansion team and
we're hopping over to that and so like
I'm one of these eyes and like long time
listeners in my podcast don't want to
hear me say this again but like my big
problem with partisanship today is that
it stems from the fact that the parties
are so weak not that they're so strong
because weak parties create strong
partisanship because politics starts to
become essentially a secular religion
for people and if the parties actually
had a better
and more responsible fiduciary sense of
their own obligations to protect their
brand and to protect what they believe
in
Bernie Sanders never would have been
allowed to run in the primaries for
president and the Democratic party and
Donald Trump never would have been
allowed to run in the primaries for
president in the Republican party and
what we need are more people
who say
um I'm here in this position for a
reason
and the institution that I'm at is more
important than my personal desire to be
a Twitter celebrity or a social media
influencer and all the rest
one of the problems I have with and it
gets back to where we started this
conversation but the guy shot tongue and
everything being saturated with politics
I want more people to stay in their
freaking Lanes
and I and when you live in a society
where
every single CEO feels like they have to
put forth a statement on every political
controversy of the day where every
single freaking Hollywood star feels
like they have to check every box when
they accept an Oscar where every store
look we I'll I can defend the black
lives matter movement in all sorts of
ways but like requiring every single
store to put up a sign in its window is
kind of creepy and
um when we live in this era where
everyone has to wear their badges about
all of their ideological commitments it
makes it very hard for institutions to
do their jobs
and that's about the whole Dei stuff and
the sort of you know the social justice
stuff with corporations I think it's
very different dangerous because I want
widget companies to make widgets
and we live in a society now where
everybody feels like they have to
exploit institutions for their own
self-aggrandizement rather than actually
serve and give themselves over to
institutions to make them better and to
make themselves better and I think
that's a real problem in our society I
don't disagree with you about that uh in
many ways and I think the question then
becomes why were these institutions so
weak
um and better happen and what is the
role of the people who ran the
institutions in destroying them
um and then also how do you how do you
rebuild trust and confidence in
institutions because that you know
that's the thing when you look at the
last 50 or so years there's a straight
line decline in trust and confidence in
institutions both public sector and
private sector and philanthropic
um and mostly that's not because we are
just horrible human beings it's because
those institutions
failed their missions in profound ways
and didn't take responsibility for it I
think but and I agree that you know we
are not simply jumping from Iceberg to
Iceberg all the time I often am accused
of being this kind of arch and
individualist where there's you know you
are born without a past and you're not
enmeshed in a social political cultural
economic system and you can just do
whatever you want I don't think that at
all
um I just think you know at every moment
we should be expanding the scope of
choice for individuals to discover and
to act on how they want to live but I I
think there's a lot of value in what
you're saying there well that that's uh
what that brings me to what I hope we
can kind of wrap this conversation up
with which is what is an alternative
vision of how to rebuild those
institutions because like when I look at
Europe it's like the options are this
kind of right-wing populism there's
democratic socialism there's the kind of
progressive technocrats and then when I
look at the U.S the options aren't
really that much different
um but that seem to be presented at
least in the form of you know the major
uh influences within our our two major
parties so I I guess that's what I would
like to put to each of you is like what
would you like to see like what
competitor to those Visions
um you know could plausibly arise that
that you would advocate for
um Okay so
uh
two points one
um I want to see a lot less transparency
but a lot more accountability
um
I think one of the problems we have I
think C-SPAN is full of patriotic people
and it was a great thing and all that
but putting cameras on Congress has made
con has helped make Congress suck
um and having an eyeball where the
public where it is literally impossible
to have serious negotiations of any kind
when they're in front of cameras and I
think that's one of the things that
really weakened institutions
um I want
less democracy within institutions
particularly within the political
parties
um the political scientists used to talk
about how
democracy is what happens between
parties not within parties
um I would get rid of the primaries I
think they've been a huge problem
but then lastly I I think
in you know Nick has heard me give the
Spiel many times over the last five
thousand years but
um
Federalism is the only friggin real
answer for a lot of this stuff
um
if you send power down on those local
level possible first of all it is
impossible to have one size fits all
politics from above and I think one of
the things picking up on again on this
theme that we've been talking about all
along
one of the things that really Riles
people on the left and the right is this
one size fits-all sort of cultural
imposition from above thing they you
know it's like
why should I why do people in San
Francisco have any reason to tell people
in South Carolina how to live
and there's this feeling that that
abstract sort of like Maloney stuff
about financial speculators that there
are these cold unseen people from very
far away
who are running my life
and if you send power down the most
local level possible you will still have
cultural war fights
you'll still have disagreements
but
um
you'll know who to fire
right because the official the powers
that be will have names you'll see them
at Town meetings and whatnot and
moreover in the sort of populist fights
about whether it's gay marriage or
transgender stuff or whatever
you'll still have those disagreements
but the winners have to look the losers
in the eye they'll see each other at
soccer games they'll see each other at
um you know the supermarket or a church
or whatever and that creates a certain
amount more of Civility and humility in
people and I think that one of the
things that that
is the real danger in politics that
creates these populist back crashes
creates all of these different
ideological movements that search for
meaning to fill the holes in their souls
is people don't understand that a lot of
things just don't work at scale
um you know even Rousseau thought that
uh his sort of General will soft
totalitarianism or hard totalitarianism
stuff couldn't work anywhere larger than
the city state of Geneva
um
people like
people are only wired to know as human
beings like a hundred it's called
dunbar's number like 150 people
everybody else beyond that is sort of an
abstraction
and um when you have a central power
centralized government trying to say
this is how everybody has to live
[Music]
um
it creates all sorts of problems because
you're going to get mad at people who
are abstractions and who aren't real
people inside of your head so send it
all down to the most local level
possible
this is the most mobile country in the
most mobile time in the history of
humanity
if you're a libertarian-minded person
and you're stuck somewhere where the
rules don't let you have booze on a
Saturday night or whatever you can
either argue democratically against it
or you can move
um but that's what I was sort of meaning
about better about real diversity I want
this country to be a more interesting
place to drive across where more people
get to live the way they want to live
including in large groups
yep that sounds good to me um what what
about you Nick is that uh jive with your
vision of where we need to head yeah uh
yes in in large part but I also think
um there are you know and this is where
libertarianism Ron Bailey and I have
talked about this a lot and I know uh
Jonah who used to work with were on way
way back when had similar conversations
but there is something totalizing about
libertarianism because it will say at
some root level certain rights cannot be
legislated away sure you know and so
there was there should be more diversity
there should be more experiments in
living uh is the way you know to use
John Stewart Mill's phrase uh that are
that are currently happening but I I
also just without getting into kind of
political maneuvering and things like
that
um I also think we need to start with
the recognition that things are actually
much better than we sure talk about we
you know in just the 21st century we
went through 9 11 to terrible Wars that
were you know bad
um we went through one of the biggest
the biggest Financial collapse and and
financial crisis since the Great
Depression we had covet uh you know
there's all these things and we are
actually doing really really well as a
society people are not starving uh
they're you know what we can do is first
acknowledge that we are actually doing
pretty well uh another thing that I
think we need to cultivate and I I'm not
exactly sure how to do this but is to
cultivate a sense of history and
appreciation I mean the the reason why I
remain optimistic and the reason why I
want to see more experiments in living
is because my parents were born in the
1920s and they were raised in slums and
ghettos they went through the depression
in World War II
um and you know I am a general
generation removed from welfare and my
kids are doing much better than I am and
I'm not saying that that means everybody
is or that if you're not doing well it's
your fault but it's like the amount of
progress that has happened in America in
the past 100 years is phenomenal and
it's also replicated throughout the
globe and we do not take any account of
that we don't think about things that
are older than a couple of weeks
and that leaves us in a kind of
delusional state that the world is
always about to end and that you know we
are one or two gay marriage laws away
from complete you know you know mental
chaos and civilizational collapse or the
environment is about to you know burn up
um and these are idiotic responses to
being alive at this time and I think
starting with an appreciation of that as
well as a recognition of you know
anything that is human is not alien to
us and that we you know we are in a very
good moment in time that we can make
better by actually becoming more uh
committed to something like pluralism
and tolerance and all both you know all
of the disruption that that entails but
also all of the humility uh that it
forces upon each of us when we start to
tell people how to live
that's uh thank you so much both you I
think we'll we'll end the stream there
and thanks for everyone who watched uh
we'll see you next week
hi thanks Shawna thanks for having me